lula reapareció en la política brasileña
luego de que el tribunal supremo anulara
las condenas que tenía el expresidente
por corrupción
luiz inácio lula da silva dijo que fue
una víctima de la injusticia se que fue
víctima de la mayor mentira legal en los
500 años de historia contada
a pesar de que la decisión de la corte
le permite ser candidato
lula dice que no piensa postularse para
las próximas elecciones presidenciales
mi cabeza no tiene tiempo para pensar en
la candidatura 2022
pero el exmandatario tampoco negó la
posibilidad de un regreso al contrario
enfatizó que quiere volver a hablar con
los brasileños para defender al país del
mal que causa ya ir bolsón a lula le
dedicó varias de sus frases al
presidente de extrema derecha y afiló
sus críticas hacia la economía y el
manejo de la pandemia hubo un presidente
que inventó la cloroquina color opina
y un presidente que dijo que los que le
tienen miedo al cob y 19 son
que el hobbit era sólo una pequeña gripe
que el hobbit era algo para cobardes que
él era un ex deportista y que no le
afectaría
y ese no es el papel de un presidente de
la república en un país civilizado que
dice
lula habló desde la sede del sindicato
de trabajadores del metal en las afueras
de sao paulo fue justo allí donde
comenzó su campaña presidencial en 2012
antes de ser presidente durante siete
años y ahora sin condenas por corrupción
en su contra podría volver a la arena
política